what is happening there reject nation
greg here thank you so much for clicking
on this video i woke up this morning to
discover this marvel studios what if
clip has dropped and it's called
steve based off of the thumbnail i can
only assume that it's about steve
rogers i have friends friends on the
internet friends whose channels you
might have seen already who have seen
the first
three episodes of what if i have not yet
but
they all gave it some really high praise
and i've said it's really damn good so
i'm very excited for it you
best bet we are going to be doing
reactions for right here on the channel
so please subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reactions for the episodes start
rolling out and i'll just ask this right
up front other than what's been teased
already in the trailers
what other what if versions of marvel
characters are you hoping to see
pop up in the show or maybe even in
season two so yeah guys gonna do a
reaction and give some thoughts on this
clip afterwards
let's hop into it
[Music]
hey peggy now you owe me one
hold on a second she's friends with that
that hydra stomper
i think i'm friends with him too
all right guys i like that clip quite a
bit
very very enjoyable and to actually get
a real clip and get a better sense
of like the animation it's like i know
the trailer show you quite a bit but
it's nice to actually
settle into an a little bit of a scene
so you can get a better flare for it
kind of similar to how i felt about
spider-man into the spider-verse
uh kind of because it's definitely not
the same type of animation but it emits
the same kind of a
emotional response that i had with that
which is
wow this really does look like a comic
book panel coming to life and to know
that we're going to get multiple
episodes like this
that is awesome that just gets me super
duper excited and i have heard like it's
other
director or creator who's come out
recently wanted to make it definitively
clear that marvel studios what if the
yes it might be an animated series and
it's going to be alternate versions but
this
is considered canon just because it's
animated just because it's a multiverse
and alternate scenarios does not mean
it's not canon this
is canon because the multiverse is now
canon within the mcu
if i'm not mistaken i've been hearing
quite a few reports
that captain carter is supposed to
appear
in doctor strange 2 multiverse madness
just being reported
doesn't know for sure yet either way
that's cool
because the fact that it's canon means
that we have potential
for any of these iterations any of these
you know
what if scenarios to come to life in
live action which i think is great
kind of like how you know the
mandalorian was able to bring in you
know ahsoka tano and bokuton characters
introduced from animated properties
bring them into live action and now we
can do the same thing
here but with marvel it's a great time
to be
living in franchise world and i'll admit
to you know there's a part of me that's
extremely happy to see uh i think his
name is neil mcdonough i i believe
that's his i don't know his voice
that well but it sounded like his voice
neil mcdonough to come back here as
dugan because i really liked him in the
first captain
america movie and i think he's a pretty
great actor quite an underrated one
at that too he played him bison and
street fighter the legend of chun li
maybe i shouldn't reference that one
he's great in the first captain america
movie i'm excited to see him back here
again and hang out with that character
even more so you know of course
that that's got to be sebastian stan i
mean he just came off falcon winner
soldier
i'm sure it's not hard for him to walk
across the disney plus hall and then
make a little guest appearance here for
one episode or maybe he's in more
you know what's cool about having bucky
back here is that we didn't spend too
much time with him in captain america
the first avenger
and like he was off screen for a bit uh
quite a bit of it because he got
captured
and and then you know we all know what
happens he fell off the train but we
didn't get to spend too much time with
him as that
more hopeful optimistic soldier before
he became the winter soldier
and even though this is a what-if
scenario
you're still going to be able to spend a
little bit more time with bucky barnes
as
that version does that james barnes
version before
any of those like terrible body horror
things happen to the guy
captain carter looks great i really want
hayley atwell to appear
as uh captain carter and dr strange
multiverse of madness i love that look
at when she's
steve and her the way her our eyes light
up such a great look but of course you
know steve rogers the man of the hour
here
so awesome because it's like yeah the
reason why steve rogers was chosen for
the super soldier serum was not because
of brute strength or physical
necessity it was because of who he is
internally
the way how like dr abraham erskine said
it he was chosen because of his heart
i'm paraphrasing there but that's
essentially what it is this is a great
demonstration of
why he is chosen because even without
the super soldier serum he's still going
to go up against the baddies he's still
going to go up against the bullies
still stand up for what's right he's
going to show everyone that that's
america's skinny ass
he's going to [ __ ] all over some nazis i
mean yes i like he's got this hydra
stomper suit so he's not
completely vulnerable it's just skinny
steve rogers
but let's face it i mean i feel i
personally would
imagine it would feel safer to be
injected with super soldier serum versus
having a hydra stomper suit
because while bulletproof that is like
he's got this protective armor and
it feels like a lethal weapon you know
there's nothing more
safe than you know being as impenetrable
as
like someone with the captain america
builder you don't need armor and all
that but i think it's really cool
to see that we're going to get this
version of steve rogers that is not
going to be dependent at all on super
soldier serum that we're going to be
like hey yeah
even with if he'd never had it he would
still go out there in the battlefield
and fight
and a lot of comments were in the last
trailer reaction that we did were
stating that steve gets
his suit from uh howard start the iron
rodgers
that steve will get his suit from howard
stark this
time around and i i don't know if that's
a spoiler because
it seemed like everyone knew it but me
but apparently so that that's the case
anywho guys what did you think about
this clip are you excited for it
which alternate version of an mcu
character
are you most excited for which one do
you
want which one are you hoping really
comes to fruition in live action
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button keep a lookout for any and
all related marvel content that we cover
especially what if which is
next week wow all right guys hey let's
do a
i wanted to say a happy belated birthday
to rosa parra i think on the day we gave
you a shout out on this channel
last month i believe it was on your
birthday and like a total ass i
completely forgot to say
happy birthday so i'm here to make it up
to you today to say happy belated
birthday
you've been kicking so much ass in 2021
during 2020 when it was such a
challenging time for a lot of us and
still is a challenging time
more so last year you still managed to
grow your business grow your brand
so much and you've been like one of our
longest supporters ever and it's really
great to still have you here that
no matter how how verified you become on
all these websites and such
and that you're still here showing your
support for us we don't need a what if
multiverse scenario to declare that in a
lot of ways you are a superhero
especially
in our lives rosa i love you keep
kicking all the ass you've been kicking
everywhere
up and down film street and
health street you've been doing a lot
i'm really grateful for you
you rock i love you my dear hopefully
i'll talk with you soon